- I hope so, I mean, I
had a great interview
with Colin Quinn and he
just had a book come out
and he was talking about how
we live in such crazy times
that the extremes are
telling the independents
that they're crazy.
(Rubin laughs)
And he was saying, you know,
this is the majority of people,
how crazy is it that people ...
He is like, they're the craziest
they're the ideologues.
(upbeat music)
- It's Locals week here
on the Rubin report
and I'm doing a series
of mini interviews
with creators on why they
decided to become less reliant
on Big Tech and instead own
their content, community
and livelihood with locals.com.
Joining me today is comedian
and host of the dumpster fire,
Bridget Phetasy, welcome
back to the Rubin report.
- Thank you for having
me, always a pleasure.
- It's nice to see you again,
before we get into your..
- It's been too long,
- Your locals community,
and you were literally the first
person that I got on Locals
besides me, I thought
we'd talk a little bit
about why...
I thought you'd be
the right person,
and it's because you are trying
sorta like I'm trying, I think,
to bring a little civility
back to discourse,
how's that going for you?
- It's going well in the
community.(Rubin laughs)
I mean it is, the last
debate we did a live chat,
which was really fun because
that's like the best feature
ever that brings everybody back
to kind of a chat room vibe,
which is amazing.
And everybody loved
it, and we did.
And you know, I had
some Biden supporters
some completely independent
some people who
just aren't voting,
people who are pro-Trump,
all of us were in the chat,
everybody was laughing,
nobody was fighting.
It was very civil, people
were having disagreements,
but still being cordial to
one another, it was amazing.
So I believe that
it's still out there.
- Is it weird that you have
to sort of cultivate a space
for that?
Like, I think what intrinsically
comes to people like me
and you pretty obviously,
pretty simply naturally
that these days
it's just like gone.
- Yeah. I think it's...
I feel like it's less gone in
real life than it is online.
So I think if you got a
group of people together,
they probably would
Even if they fell all across
the political spectrum,
I would hope they would
manage to be civil.
And I imagine they
would be more civil
than perhaps they
would be online
although everybody being
quarantined and being online,
I feel like some of that
decorum has eroded in that time
and people are forgetting
how to behave online and off
completely.
And they're becoming more
and more kind of polarized
or entrenched in
their own beliefs.
So it seems like things
because of the pandemic,
it kind of accelerated this
already rude and nasty tone
that we were already
seeing amongst people.
But I do think, you know,
online, it's worse obviously
people are much they're...
We are anonymous
I really encourage
people in the community
to use their name, to
use their picture too,
so that we can get to know
each other and help each other
and have it feel more
like a neighborhood
and less like a social media
where everybody's just, you
know, outwitting each other
and trying to be the snarkiest.
- Yeah one of things
that you push a lot
that I always appreciate
is that it's not
all about politics.
Like, even if you love politics,
even if you live politics
and I love politics
and what I've been
doing for a long time,
but that life is just
not about only that.
- Yeah, I hate politics
(both laugh)
And falling into this space has
made me hate them even more.
And it's only affirmed
everything that
I believed before
I knew anything about politics,
which is that they're dirty
and they bring out kind
of the worst in people.
And it's not my favorite topic.
And my community is very...
You know, I'm sober,
so I try to talk a lot
about just what I've
learned in coping tools.
I feel grateful to have
learned it in sobriety.
You don't have to be
sober to have access
to a lot of this stuff.
And my whole podcasts
Walk-ins Welcome
is about grit and resilience.
And so I do my best to...
That psychological
cultivation of that attitude
is really the most
important thing to me.
And I think in the community,
that's the vibe of everybody
supporting each other.
I have workouts with the
girls five days a week.
So we do zoom workouts
and it's been amazing.
I mean, this community
has truly saved me
throughout quarantine
and in the pandemic
just keeping me on the beam
and working out and working
on ourself and sharing goals.
And I've seen people help
each other through death.
I've seen people help each
other through health struggles.
It's just been really
inspiring to see
this virtual community
support each other
the way that community should.
- Yeah. Well, it's funny to me
because you're right, like we
all got sort of jammed online
even more because of COVID.
We knew there was like a problem
with the online discourse
and then the solution somehow
is that we're all online,
even more and doing
everything there.
And it's like, we
need those spaces.
I'm having dinners with
people in the community
and we've hired several
people for Rubin Report
and for Locals that have
come out of the community
and all that.
One of the things that I
think you're trying to do
also is carve out a space
for people to still be,
still be centrist.
Do you think the centrist
thing can survive
the crazy part is in
times that we live in?
- I hope so. I mean, I
had a great interview
with Colin Quinn and he
just had a book come out
and he was talking about how
we live in such crazy times
that the extremes are
telling the independents
that they're crazy.
(Rubin laughs)
And he was saying, you
know, "this is the majority
of people, how crazy
is it that people...
He's like, they're the crazies,
they're the ideologues,
they're the ones who are extreme
and will die on whatever hell
and carry, you know, whatever
water they need to carry,
to justify whatever they need
to justify to themselves."
And I think people in
the middle, you know,
more than anything, I just
want people to be okay
with expressing confusion.
Or expressing doubt or
expressing uncertainty
or expressing the I don't know,
that's a perfectly
acceptable answer.
And these times it is
crazy out there. And so...
- Wait a minute, wait a minute.
Are you saying you don't know
how much yellow cake uranium
(indistinct) in centrifuges is?
- No, I know nothing.
- Do they even put yellow
cake uranium in centrifuges?
That just sounds like something.
(Bridget laughs)
- I know, less than nothing.
The more I've entered
into this realm
the more I've realized, I
know it's so very little
about anything.
And it's easy to just get
online and become an expert
in whatever is trending
because you can Wikipedia things
and become this kind
of armchair expert
in any single
thing that pops up.
But really, we don't know that
much unless we are experts.
And I'm okay with
being kind of the dummy
who is asking a
lot of questions.
And that's the other thing
I'm noticing is that people
are afraid to even
ask questions.
It's not even vote for X, Y, Z.
If you don't say...
If you say I'm not voting
or I'm voting third party,
you will basically be
called a fascist as well.
- You are a facilitator
or something
- It's fascinating
to me to just see how
that there's a loss of
people being able to speak
their free and honest
opinion and truth,
and so more important than
anything is that we all continue
to cultivate spaces
where that's okay.
Where people feel like
they can just say,
I mean, I can't tell you how
many emails I get from people
who are politically homeless,
who are like, I don't
even care if you read this
that just felt so good to say.
Because they don't have
anywhere they can express this.
So I'm hoping that my
community can be that place
where people can
express their confusion.
I think Jack Kerouac
had a great quote.
"I have nothing to offer the
world, but my confusion."
I feel like that's
very much my vibe.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Well, I've jumped into your
community and I just kind of see
what's going on, it's like
people are sharing other things
besides politics, and they're
trying to help each other out.
And it's like that
really remember...
- Lotta foodies
- The word social,
is in social media.
It's like it was supposed
to make... Right foodies,
and what do you have
for dinner and all that?
I mean half of my community
is just doing recipes
and dinners, but it's like,
- (indistinct)
- You're smiling as
you're saying it,
because it's like, Oh, there's
something good happening
there, but it's like,
people are on Twitter
just telling you how miserable
they are all day long
and yet we're there too. So_
- Yeah.
- Irony, whatever.
- Yeah. I mean, I like
Twitter because I really feel
like it's the Thunderdome.
So you get to just...
It's very hard to
be free there too.
And I like to challenge
myself on Twitter
because it's an exercise
in what I'm not saying.
So when it first started,
when I first went on Twitter
and started getting noticed
even by people on the right
you'll lean into what's working.
And I generally have this rule
where wherever I have a tweet
that goes really big,
I'll do the opposite.
Or I'll say something just so
that I can weed out anybody
who might think that I'm
too much of a, you know,
you can see one tweet
and be like, Oh, I know
who this person is,
but I need to weed out the
people who can't handle
differing opinions.
Because on both sides there
are people who can't handle
you saying anything
bad about Trump
or anything bad about
the left.(chuckles)
- Yeah. Where do you
see the internet going
in the next couple of years?
Do you think think
these big things
that they'll exist still,
it seems like everything's
kind of crumbling.
Maybe they'll look
very different.
I've been asking
everybody this question.
- Yeah, that's a good question.
I don't know where anything
will be in two years or three
in the future.
I feel like all of the
things that we never
could have considered
possible are playing out
are happening.
So I have to really,
really get my mind around
being comfortable
with being uncertain
and not really having
any idea what...
I think Twitter will survive.
My feeling...
Even seeing my 12 year old
nephew now loves Twitter
because it is the
fastest social media
in terms of the conversation.
And it is this think tank for
all of these kinds of thought
people and the conversation
is kind of happening there.
I wouldn't be surprised
as if it survives,
but it seems like the
forces to silence people.
And I'm seeing this even...
Like I was in clubhouse
last night, holy crap!
I mean, wow, wow.
- I don't even know really
I got an invite a long
time ago, I logged on once
and I was like, I don't
need to like listen
to these people talk.
I dunno, like we need more.
- It was like a zoo. It's a zoo.
It's amazing.
It's, you know, what
I really love about it
is that it's basically
like being at a conference
and you can just go pop in
and listen to a panel of
speakers. That's how I see it.
But then with the
introduction of people
that make people in
there not feel safe,
it's caused a lot of discussion,
the same discussions that
happen on every single platform
about who's allowed
to be speaking,
who is allowed to be where.
And so this is the conversation
that I think will alter
all of these platforms the
most, you know, Twitter,
Facebook, who is
allowed to speak where.
And why I love Locals is
because I feel like a mouse
and I've have talked about this.
At least we get a phone
call before we get booted.
- I mean, you can do
whatever you want.
It's up to you. As long as
you're not breaking the laws
of the United States, you
know, you've shown a little,
a little more skin than
say I've shown on mine.
But as long as...I don't
care what you do in there,
I mean the whole you
know, development team,
they don't care.
It's your community it's
like, we're just giving you
some tools you go
do what you want.
- Yeah. It's great.
It feels very free.
And I like that.
And you know, it's
really empowering
in that I have...
It goes through like
my Stripe account.
I feel like that's the
most empowering thing
because I've been a lot
of these other sites
and it's goes to them. We get
paid out. We have to wait.
This is truly
giving the creators,
the tools to their audience
and access to their audience
and not being a gatekeeper.
Because in this time, when there
are gatekeepers everywhere,
and you can just get
booted off a platform
and sorry you now have
to fight for your stuff
and fight for your audience
and now scramble
to tell everybody.
This feels a lot
more empowering.
And I think that
that is the future.
And it's the most exciting,
one of the most exciting things,
other than just the sexiness
of the actual design
and platform about Locals
for me as a creator.
- Yeah. Just to be clear
for people that don't get
what you're saying.
It's your Stripe account,
meaning if you're a creator
on there,
- Right.
- It's your personal
Stripe account.
So Locals doesn't collect
the money on your behalf
and then pay you. Your
paid as people sign up,
then Locals gets their cut,
but it all goes through you.
So there's no middlemen
- Well they subscribing
- And yeah, exactly.
And in my case, they're
subscribing to Phetasy Inc.
I mean this is an amazing,
and people just kind of assume
that that's the way it was,
because that's the way it is.
And the fact that Locals
has made that very small,
but obvious shift in
the way that this works
is I think enormously important
for creators in this space,
moving forward when
things are shifting
and people are being de
platformed and silenced
and booted.
- Phetasy you're making me look
good for picking you first.
(Phetasy laughs)
- I'm a business
woman (both laugh)
- All right, well, everyone
can go to phetasy.locals.com
or just phetasy.com,
just redirects to locals.
And I hope to see you in
real life one of these days,
my friend.
- I know.
- This digital thing.
- Let's do this
- No, I know it's overdue.
- Alright, we'll set it up.
- But thank you for creating
this and thank you to the team.
You have an amazing team behind
you and working with you,
and they're all very
loving and supportive,
and brilliant and talented.
So I appreciate all their help.
And I want them to know that
I see how hard they work
and what they're doing,
and it doesn't go unnoticed
with me or my community.
I hear about it all the time
from them. So thank you.
- Awesome, well I
love to hear that
and they'll be
happy to hear that.
Alright, Bridget,
we'll talk soon.
- All right. Thank you.
(upbeat music)
- If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about comedy,
instead of the nonstop yelling,
you get everywhere else,
check out our comedy playlist.
And if you wanna watch full
interviews on a variety
of topics, check out our
full episode playlist
they're both right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.